it's exceptionally rare today guys for
you to run into a woman that's not
brainwashed by
um modern culture post-modernism
uh liberalism whatever you want to call
it
it's
it's interesting because
i have conversations with family friends
friends of family in-laws you know all
that sort of stuff
and there's always just like a random
drop of like oh that's misogynistic or
some other you know popular sound bite
that's going on or right now xenophobic
homophobic global phobic whatever the
flow blicks are that they keep stacking
on top of each other and piling up
but the point remains is
both men and women have been polluted by
this
new narrative of
where
you know where we got to today there is
a there is a here let me show this to
you
because i like i like to chuck in my
visuals right
so what when i was a kid i was a boy
scout okay and
when i was a boy scout
the kinds of things we used to do were
we'd have to have contests like see if
you can start a fire with just one match
and you'd have to go into a forest and
you'd get like birch bark and kind of
peel it off a tree but not so much that
it hurts the tree but just enough that
it's good to start a fire because they
would lecture you on that they tell you
know peeling off too much birch bark is
like peeling off the skin on a human why
would you do that to a tree so not only
do they teach you masculinity traits but
they also taught you con like most of
these vegan nerds are right now marching
around don't even know that probably but
they would teach boy scouts how to light
a fire with one match they would have
you compete they would have you um
set up camp play capture the flag
um
[ __ ] like all like all this cool [ __ ]
that we used to do when i was a kid
british bulldog murder ball murder ball
was a big thing too right like we used
to do
murder ball massively tons
and this here is a video that showed up
in my timeline of my twitter and it says
uh now boy scouts are marching in
seattle at the pride parade and you see
these young boys with the various flags
and stuff like that and i couldn't
imagine
any of the i can't remember what they
call them troopers or troops or
something like that
um
but like the boy scout leaders ever say
anything like okay guys we're not gonna
play british bulldog today which is
basically like
two teams running across the field
smashing into each other beating the
[ __ ] out of each other it was like like
kids would get hurt i remember i
remember there was one kid that broke a
bone there's
quite a few times kids got scraped up
but
that was part of it right like that's
part of playing british bulldog or
murder ball you get hit in the head with
a ball as fast as some kid can whip it
you're gonna feel it
now
you know the priority is uh marching
with what's trending you know with
whatever flag is trending or whatever's
going on that time time of the month or
whatever it happens to be yeah troop
leaders thanks moth but yeah that's
that's where we're at today i bet none
of these boy scout kids can light a fire
with one match
i i doubt they ever play british bulldog
unlikely
or murder ball
they probably took
i would assume because it's called
murder ball or dodgeball is like the
friendly name i would assume that
they've taken that out of most school
systems or most most extracurricular
groups whether it's boy scouts or
brownies or whatever it happens to be
but yeah
that was one of the things that you know
got me all fired up about doing this
podcast and
and then you know this morning i saw
this interview with uh andrew tate
trending with some
pretty girl who was a covert feminist i
mean you can't define it any other way
than that and it's like
she wanted to
typical modern woman tip like typical
like you like guys run into these chicks
all the time it's like
well i want to be treated like a lady
and have doors open for me and take me
out on dates and dress me up all pretty
in flowers and [ __ ] but if you cheat i'm
going to cheat too and it's the exact
same [ __ ] thing right
and
this entire narrative of like what's
good for the goose is good for the
gander it's it's so bizarre because they
want the old school yeah pay for my [ __ ]
and house me and put babies in me and
let's make a family but they also want
to brow beat the [ __ ] out of the guy or
pretend like they're uh at the very
least well they call it equality like
let's be equals like aren't we equals
now but the truth of matter is is
feminism isn't about equality it's about
it's a superiority movement okay uh it's
a supremacy movement more than anything
it doesn't like men um at all
um
in fact
it's it's it's quite hostile and that's
why
you know when you hear me talk about
things like
i don't know divorce law you know for
example your or child or child custody
issues you know for example
um
it's like it's fully infused and all of
that that's just the way that is it's at
right
it's crazy let me get some of these
super chats that have been popping up
here
um
see the reason why i like the members
only chat and i will turn it on when it
becomes available available to me is
it's easier for me to follow through in
the chat otherwise it just it just goes
insane to find super chats oh hey glenn
uh here's my prediction in a row versus
wade alpha are going to smash hotties
hotties will become mommies bettas will
marry mommies in exchange for access to
her victoria secrets that's pretty much
what happens right now
um the whole like roe versus weight
thing like i don't really care about it
to be honest with you it's like whatever
i mean
i don't see the problem right there's at
least a dozen probably two dozen forms
of birth control abortion isn't birth
control i don't care
you know whatever side of the fence
you're on to me it's a moot point right
like just don't be a hoe and use birth
control if you're gonna have uh sex
whatever
but that's you know that's the new thing
everybody's gotta be mad about that
right now there's um
somebody uh sent me a couple of
screenshots to a few uh tweets with um
women on dating apps now are demanding
that you have a vasectomy before
uh they'll go out with you
or they're looking for proof of a
vasectomy before and then you see the
photographs of like these women that you
have available to you if you have a
vasectomy and they're
atrocious like
okay i don't want to get into like
describing but you know what i'm saying
when i'm saying it because these things
on youtubes can be problematic but you
know what i'm saying
i'm sure you've seen it hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you